We Begin this hour with a story of how a
handful of people came together with one
shared goal to help an unhoused man
Cashman Whiteley is seen here on the
cover of a local newspaper back in
August with a simple headline you see he
became homeless when his life spiraled
out of control and he couldn't break out
of it lead National correspondent David
begno met with Whiteley and shares the
story of how whiteley's Community
stepped in to help
I didn't want to do this story
and have you look like a fish in a
fishbowl that we were just looking at
okay
and I appreciate that because
respect
is a good starting point
meet Cashman Cashman Whiteley you have
had an incredible amount
of kindness shown your way here lately I
sure have and I am grateful for every
bit of it Whiteley has no home
but for the past few weeks he's been
sleeping here at the home of Carmen
Flores and her partner Tatiana Guerrero
they had seen him on the street looking
really sick and sleeping in front of a
church on a cement cold slab and the
church didn't open its doors I was like
okay if our institutions aren't doing it
then we have to do something as a Young
Man Whiteley traveled America working
carnivals yeah I see your peanut butter
money he says was always tight and after
a divorce the life of this father of
three spiraled
in 2000 he landed in Southern California
didn't have money to uh run a place to
live I didn't know
you know a way to get started
so he simply wound up on the sidewalk
could you find a job no after 10 years
with the carnival I had no verifiable
job references
I have no dress
and at the time no phone number no the
employers got they had their standards
and I'm below it
I had been told go away no you can't
have a job application because you're
homeless and how does that feel cash
actually if I hear one more time I'm
going to melt down because it's wrong
because if I'm actually human being I
should have the same chances as
everybody else
the 59 year old avoids homeless shelters
I have ADHD attention deficit
hyperactivity disorder
I am not accepted by other homeless
people I don't drink and don't use drugs
I'm Different in the Earth
this is the story about how a group of
people in Claremont California who did
not know each other stepped up to help
him and in the process they saved his
life starting with Flores and Guerrero
who housed him and fed him Jesus left us
this Sacrament Jesse Smith is a part of
that group too
she is pastor of Saint Ambrose Episcopal
Church where Whiteley showers twice a
week and attends Services Pastor Smith
who along with her husband has taken
Whiteley to multiple doctors
appointments says he gets offended when
people don't treat him as if he matters
I saw it over and over going to the
emergency rooms with him
calling the paramedics having the police
called him on him here or there or
wherever
he said not seen it as a human he was
seen as a nuisance Whiteley had been
ignoring a growth on the left side of
his face until the pain became
unbearable it was so bad that I just
screamed uncontrollably I mean literally
that top of my lungs and people would
call the police and the idea was get rid
of him you ever take me to the clinic
the clinic would send me to a
dermatologist the dermatologist would
just say well just just put this cream
on it or
to treat his antibiotics which weren't
working
and then I'd be screaming again
and this went on for a year Dr David
nassa is a retired pathologist who met
Whiteley on the street he called some of
those agencies that were giving him the
runaround they kept calling and it
eventually threatening and what makes
you emotional
well seeing somebody suffer like that in
front of everybody and nobody was taking
any initiative nobody cared about him he
tried to get something done
now for that I can say
he has tried to be a good friend
the diagnosis was skin cancer he wanted
immunotherapy but his Medicaid insurance
plan didn't cover that so that's when
counselors at City of Hope a
comprehensive cancer center gave him
just that hope they helped him to change
his insurance so that he would qualify
for the care he wanted
Flores and Guerrero who both work in the
healthcare industry went with him to
advocate for him this is much better
that immunotherapy is working wonders
how do you feel well I feel a lot better
than I did three weeks ago
three weeks ago I feel like I was dying
and I probably was if you ask him how he
feels about Flores and Guerrero I think
they saved my life because he probably
did so much changed in your life just in
those three weeks you were with them
it's only because of one thing
they really do care
Reverend Jesse Smith
she really cares my friend Dr Dave neska
really cares why don't we end this with
me giving you a hug why not okay
with people like these in my life
I've got a land on my feet I could
actually see a brighter much brighter
future it's in good shape oh you better
believe it only has 82 000 miles on it
well that future got even brighter back
in January Flores and Guerrero took him
to look at a vehicle and he liked it we
asked that it be something that helped
him in his journey moving forward an
anonymous donor gave Pastor Smith the
money for Whiteley to buy it in the name
of the father
and the Sun and the very next day some
members of the congregation were there
when it was blessed how much money do
you have now I got about 20 hours and
three quarters of tank yes
not too bad
where are you sleeping
I'm sitting back into the car right now
you know it's because I'm still in
transition pace
right now he is convinced that better
days are ahead for him
and it is partly because of those people
showed him that he matters a month ago
was like you know will somebody just
hurry up and pulled a plug on me and
just get it over with
because I was just exhausted I can see
myself getting better now yeah I can see
myself getting back to doing some type
of meaningful work
you know
that I find very helpful
we met cash five weeks ago and I'm happy
to report that as of today the skin on
the left side of his face is healing
wonderfully I took him to lunch last
weekend and I also took this picture
but big old smile on his face ah look at
this mom wow it's a hard-earned uh smile
there David it's a powerful story what
an amazing individual to be introduced
to in that community that came to his
Aid as well uh you know and the car uh
where he is now residing uh what what is
the Outlook at this point for getting
transitional as he said out of the car
to a house
getting a job and he's working on it
Tony he used to have one the car broke
down and the place where he was staying
had the vehicle impounded so he lost the
car couldn't afford to get it out so now
with this new car he's hoping to get a
new job and he feels like that'll get
him back on his feet to where he can
find a home and a place at least a call
yeah everyone deserves one and you know
it's true what they say it gets very
expensive the less money you have right
yeah the the system starts taking things
away from you and it becomes more
difficult to get back on your feet and
that's another lesson in addition to the
lessons in kindness from your story
David thank you very much